welcome back to our vax facts for kids
town hall let's go to mom of two skyler
goodman who says she is not vaccinated
and doesn't plan on getting her children
the covid19 vaccine skylar i know you
have some time here your oldest is four
years old
you told me your concern was that you
feel that the approval process was
fast-tracked can you talk about that and
what's your question
yeah so i
definitely feel like there hasn't been
enough time to conduct long-term studies
whether or not there's been enough money
put into conducting these studies there
hasn't been long-term studies actually
put forward so from my question i would
like to ask
according to the american academy of
pediatrics the mortality rate among
children is 0 to
0.03 percent
so why should i as a parent risk my
child obtaining any side effect or
adverse reaction to the vaccine like the
many cases already seen among adults
dr e can you address schuyler's concern
here yeah absolutely so i think one
thing to point out is when you're
looking at mortality rate they're
looking at the collective mortality rate
pre-delta variant as well which we know
was milder which we know had a much
lower mortality rate so
as this continues this pandemic those
numbers may shift the other thing is you
know
how many deaths are okay and do do we
want to risk our own children as part of
that and you know here in clark county
we have had some debts already and we've
had over 90 cases where children have
had significant serious consequences
with long-term inflammatory
organ damage from it and so in in my
opinion it's kind of like a seat belt
it's not a 100 percent guarantee but i
want that layer of protection for my kid
and and for yours as well
uh skylar hearing that information and
those numbers um does that concern you
and do you feel like you're willing to
take the risk dr e is referring to
yeah i mean
considering the
mortality rate among adults i mean the
survival rate is as well 97 to 99
so to me the risk of my child obtaining
even a side effect but more so
importantly a long-term condition or an
adverse reaction to me
isn't worse than taking the vaccine when
it's not when it's shown that it's not
as effective as it could be when there's
people still getting positive coveted
results and fully vaccinated
joanne rue piper the health district
would be aware of something like
complications from the vaccine right or
what kind of information does the health
district collect
about concerns schuyler is referring to
right well if there is any
any adverse event after the vaccine we
would
get that information and then all
providers
can also report it to the government
we do know that
chill that most of the deaths and
hospitalizations that occur
are related to unvaccinated people for
vaccinated people it's a it's a small
percentage
thank you so much now when we come back
we'll hear from a parent who says he's
not an anti-vaxxer but he is against the
covid vaccine he'll tell us why you're
watching a special edition of 8 news now
at 4